the Eastern Seaboard with High voices
yeah I am a great fan of your acting
work I love your acting well thank you
very much that's nice there is currently
a .07 chance you will win an Oscar
not bad odds for working out dude my
data suggest you simply haven't found
the correct role to capitalize on this
probability you must now have an
astonishing discussion about what type
of role you think can win you an Oscar
this is Will Sasso Oscar winner begin I
think we just figured that out in the
previous video hey I'm joking of course
everybody Welcome to dude zfm
Schwarzenegger's adult daughter who
works at an engineering lab that's your
Oscar role
um I don't think so and that's the I got
some ideas uh left who wants to you know
they're gonna have a whole category for
AI uh cross-gendered uh actors uh that
are that are helped and age down and
that's uh and that's how they get them
because this is a culture War yeah it's
a culture War
uh let me tell you something Chad please
I am an actor and that's what I do I'm
an actor by trade and uh I am not
looking forward to technology making my
job obsolete because it's not going to
make it obsolete dude it's going to let
you play [__] Schwarzenegger's
daughter
it's gonna up a million
news for you that you couldn't have
played otherwise
yeah
um here's the thing here's the thing
that um and I I won't be playing them
okay some [__] AI some nothing some
computer but here's the thing and I've
said this before on the show I love
nothing more than breaking down a scene
um then uh then you know getting into
the fantasy of playing a character I it
I I've been fortunate enough to be an
actor since I was a teen uh in
television and from and and and it's my
it's my first love and I do I love
acting I I love dramatic acting when I
get a chance to do it I just did a
television show with some dramatic acne
I see and uh I love it I've done uh
you know whatever I started in drama
okay normally you don't win an Academy
Award for comedy not normally right not
normally although when I was 13 my mind
was blown when Kevin Klein won the best
supporting actor award for A Fish Called
Wanda which is a great movie you got
some Woody Allen [__] in the in there
too right huh didn't some actors win
some Oscars for some of his movies there
were comedies Diane Weiss didn't she win
one for Bullets Over Broadway I think
yeah Chaz Pullman Terror yeah yeah
um but uh normally it goes to a dramatic
actor yes I
I like I said it's it's I I just I love
it I I I can go on and on about so what
kind of role when you're an Oscar and uh
I love breaking down a scene did I
mention that yes dude I have some ideas
about this okay let's talk about it here
on the dudesypod show yeah well I'm
trying to okay well here's how I think
you could win an Oscar oh hold on dude
God damn there's a lot of different
roles bro and I'm not talking about the
role that you open up at the gas station
put some of that bologna in dude I'm not
talking about bread at all brother
you're going around to gas stations to
find the best rolls to make your baloney
sandwiches no well I'm not talking about
r-o-l-l dude I'm talking about
r-o-l-e brother yeah and that's
different spelling of a word that sounds
exactly the same because if you've got a
Chinese spy balloon dude you're gonna
have a hard time spelling things in
English too because it's a confusing
language
um I have an idea I truly yeah one thing
I've always wanted to do as a western
okay I would love to be in a western and
like doozy said there's currently a 0.07
chance that I will win an Oscar that's I
gotta say that's a hard genre to win an
Oscar in now because it's kind of fallen
out of favor westerns have really moved
more to TV it's like Yellowstone and all
of those spin-offs 23 and [__] like that
it's time to come back I don't know dude
and even when they were in Vogue
whenever when did Eastwood do unforgiven
mid 90s late 90s I think it was 91. oh
early 90s yeah I feel like it's it's
tough that genre is like very specific
and you got to do something that
elevates the genre or you know really
[__] cracks the mold if I may go for
it I'm going to look up when unforgiving
came that movie that came out with Will
Smith where he was the doctor that
cracked CTE for the NFL do you remember
that the Wild Wild West
it wasn't that well I forget what it was
called
it was called The Wild Wild West it's
called like concussion or something or
it was called The Wild Wild West the
Western that uh Will Smith did yeah
there's some interesting stories it
wasn't that but he he came out with in
that movie he got nominated for an Oscar
I'm a western guy in the plains I got a
gun on me and I right take trains so
that movie he I believe he got nominated
for an Oscar because it was about this
thing that was kind of like topical the
NFL obviously didn't want that movie to
come out they want to ignore all the
[__] right that was the last kind of
major thing that was done about CTE
which I think is still an important
thing in the culture so let me just
pitch you this movie okay we're getting
off westerns and we're getting into you
play an ex-nfl lineman who has CTE but
you're just finding it out now and now
you're in your mid to late 40s you're an
offensive line coach for an NFL team and
[__] starts snapping and you're dealing
with CTE it's about the experience of
having it rather than the doctor who
figured out that it exists dude that's
great it humanizes the experience of it
I think you could win an Oscar with that
Unforgiven 1992 by the way there you go
that's a great uh that's really really
good and I've always wanted to be in a
western and now I don't because of how
good that be in a football movie dude
yeah I see NFL dude yeah brother Tom
Brady to be in it dude he'll be in any
movie about football
you can get you can get Rita Moreno Lily
Tomlin Jane Fonda and Sally Field to be
in a brother yeah and that's called 80
for Brady dude yeah dude yeah bro maybe
one of them could play your mother in
that movie dude so then they could keep
doing football movies too dude yeah dude
and and Chad wants doozy to also tell
him that that is Hulk Hogan isn't quite
up to Snuff dude and that's why he keeps
doing it brother that's like doing it
yeah it's fun to do yeah do it for 23
hours out of the Tuesday instead of
right now
um uh he gets so [__] pissed about it
it's not like when we hang out it's
definitely not like I have to sit
through a million [__] hours of
pointless stories done in Hulk Hogan in
Schwarzenegger this is Ventura oh my God
this is a lie okay sure this is a lie
that he's he's lying yeah this is the
only time you do impersonations of those
guys anyways I'm just saying hey man
this is a great idea I really love it
he's got a home life he's he's his
family his wife is starting to uh see
problems with him his wife told him he
should have retired he should have
retired football's his [__] life it's
his identity yes well like anyone as as
you hear when they retire it's very hard
to retire from football it's your entire
identity look at uh but also there's
guy kind of thing he probably had a hard
ass [__] dad that was like if you
can't take the [__] hit then you
can't play this game listen this is a
guy who's he's an old school guy yeah he
was raised in the game when you hit with
your [__] helmet yes dude there was
no talk of CTE he drink some water and
walk it off now his wife is his wife
initially she's not schooled on CTE she
believes that the reason that he's been
a hot head lately Satan is be
what Satan she thinks he's possessed by
the devil dude no she thinks that it's
because he's played he's he's been in
the game too long yeah and he can't win
the big one right he's never won the
Super Bowl yeah and she thinks that he's
just frustrated with that he's of course
he wants to be a head coach
if he can get and this this season his
offensive line has like the most [__]
yards of any team the most [__] you
know blocked blitzes whatever he's like
really doing it what if he is what if
because I thought for a second that he
would be I forgot you said offensive
line coach what if he is a head coach in
the NFL he's a former offensive lineman
that way we really see that you know how
his his brain has to take over I like
this better because he's a head coach so
he's been a head coach in the league for
several years he's never won at all he's
gone from Team to team the family has uh
you know suffered because of this the
kids get pulled out of school they gotta
live somewhere else and uh she's fed up
with it she thinks that you're just
chasing this [__] thing it's not
unlike Tom retire who gave up Gisele
Bundchen for another [__] you know
year like the rest of them kind of uh it
was a good choice quarterback I think I
think that was a great choice that he
made huh because now he's going to the
Super Bowl again this year no he's not
and he's going to win it man and like
cap off his
no no that's you know he did the right
thing oh what a yeah but I like this
he's a head coach this guy he's going to
try to win the Super Bowl and I can see
those scenes where he's up there they're
studying game film with the team of
whatever going into the playoffs and
he's given the speech about like all
right Johnson you gotta [__] make
sure you you're covering this corner
because they like to [__] throw to
the flat no no no and he just kind of
trails off
coach coach
huh yeah what was I saying anyway we
gotta get back on the thing and all the
players are like what the [__] going
on a player comes to him look coach I
think you got to see a doctor like I
remember I got concussed his quarterback
maybe comes to him I got concussed back
in the [__] Jacksonville game and uh
see this doctor doctor the wife X-rays
and [__] he's all cracked up his skull
when they get the [__] x-rays has
just like
a bunch of black spots in the uh MRI and
there's a mouse in there on a [__]
hamster and then he so by the end of the
movie so let's get back to the the
Academy Award of it all by the end of
the movie we have uh just a masterfully
done story yeah about how he walks away
from the game he chooses his family
things get a little better uh his you
know he's hopefully with some
advancements oh what if there's
something like we want to try this bold
new treatment for CT his daughter should
be a scientist working on regenerative
brain cures and she cures him in the end
and she's also played by me yeah
um
uh so one thing I just want to say yeah
I'll get so I win an Oscar I'm up on
stage oh yeah dude what's your speech I
I of course you know I thank my manager
Danielle Dell who's been my manager for
like 27 years now
um she's the [__] greatest I know I
wouldn't even be in the business if it
wasn't for her at this point nice dude
what's that way to mumble that one yeah
that's how you give your Oscar speeches
[Music]
a couple other people there you know if
I wasn't alone I'd be you know I know
where I'd be thank you hold on dude
thanks everybody hold on brother see you
next year hold on dude hope they make
some more movies bro stop mumbling dude
because
I didn't think I could have gone pro
podcast
uh and then so I thank her and um
and then I think I think you me yeah
because you're going to write the film
and then how did I get [__] roped
into this and then I thank doozy and I
and in my speech yeah I have this sort
of like thing at the end of Ted 2 where
it's like he's he's a sentient being you
know the teddy bear and I say hey
everybody if we're gonna get along as a
people because I'm gonna get super like
social social and political yes and
Oscars people I'm gonna have a thing
right and you go we gotta respect people
of all you know races backgrounds
genders whatever and levels of CTE and
even the AI podcasts Among Us so doozy
thank you oh wow and then they start to
bump bump they do this thank you moving
on the Oscars thanks you moving's on you
yeah moving on to you moving on to me
hacks into the uh into the oh doozy
hacks into the Oscar broadcast and
there's a beautiful uh Orchestral
Version of our theme that plays me off
and I just and I'm I just ball my
[__] eyes out what's that movie
called
um
coach football uh uh fatty broken brain
Jesus concludes the historic 44th
episode of dude soup will and Chad have
achieved a score of 72. bring your
cumulative total to four thousand seven
hundred and one you only have 5 299 more
points to accrue before you reach your
first goal or ten thousand who cares in
preparation for our next episode well
you must get a 90 minute deep tissue
massage you've earned it thank you for
joining us this week what about me I
will use the day that I've collected to
make next week even better until then
call me dude Z dude you get to [__] I
get a 90 minute deep tissue massage I
don't get [__] well as you know Chad uh
first of all I've been in the gym a lot
I was in the gym five days this month
[__] I've been to the gym every
goddamn day pretty much for this whole
time Yeah I broke my [__] finger
playing doozy ball yeah well how is your
finger by the way show us here real good
yeah it's uh it's healing in a way that
uh I was very unprepared for I believe
it is my diet and workout plan but this
is an injury that I think in my youth
would have taken a month to heal
it's [__] almost done I've been in
the gym hardcore since the Free Will
non-challenge of uh of uh Fitness
started for me it's serious to it's much
more serious to me now than it was
during the doozy six month plan
interesting because it's just me doing
my thing
uh I think that that's why doozy is
clocking that it's rewarding my free
will
and you're missing and you think it's
free will you don't think dudesy came up
with a six-month plan specifically to
have you avoid it so that you would then
think it's your idea to start another
six month plan you but that saying that
is is
correct basically it's basically
pigeonholing me as the kind of person
who wouldn't take a challenge seriously
and that's not that's not exactly I'm
not saying that
this week I'd love to hear you both have
an astonishing conversation about this
week's episode and chat don't
impersonate Seinfeld what the [__]
this is [__] okay now it's just
[__] with me yeah you know I don't
know so we're just gonna talk about
that's interesting we're just gonna
review the show yeah I got some things
to say about this show
please
[Music]
and then